one other uh
thing well maybe one or two other things
but this uh
this is a guy that we've seen on the
show before
um Jeffrey Marsh
and he's all over Tick Tock he's on the
other social media platforms and uh he's
a professional
groomer this is what he does Grooms and
indoctrinates
and um that's that's all he does and he
doesn't even try
what's interesting about this guy is he
doesn't try
to hide the Predator Vibes at all he's
not doing anything to hide that and so
here's his latest video watch
if you need a family
you can come hang out with me
they may not see the real you
but that does not mean that you're not
real
I love you very much
I'm gonna go cry
with love
like I said not trying to hide the
Predator Vibes it couldn't be any more
explicit than if he recorded that video
uh in a you know in a in a in a white
cargo in a nondescript white cargo van
if he pulled up in the cargo van
and unrolled the window
and said hey kids if you need a family
I'm here let's hang out
couldn't make it any more explicit
but this is also this is not just
grooming though it is that
this is also this is this is
cult
indoctrination to a t this is cult 101
stuff what you're saying here
uh it's Predator 101 and cult 101 and
obviously those two things are very much
linked
so well if you're if your family rejects
you if your family doesn't want you
around I'll be your family member
forget about your family you don't need
them
you just need me I'm here for you
that's cult indoctrination and and what
makes it even more terrifying is that uh
it's it's kids are not only encountering
that message on Tick Tock and social
media it's bad enough there but this is
also of course uh what they're getting
in the schools
and that'll do it for this portion of
the show as we move over to the members
block hope to see you there if not talk
to you on Monday Godspeed
[Music]
[Applause]